foreign
gang member now charged with ordering
murders drug distribution and money
laundering is taken into custody after a
routine traffic stop in Ohio thank you
[Music]
all right all right I'm not going to
issue citation or anything like that or
I almost got to run the information make
sure there's no once more make sure you
guys are around we'll get you out of
here okay all right thank you body
camera video shows the June 7th traffic
stop out of Sandusky Township Ohio where
a state patrol Trooper pulled over a
vehicle for tailgating inside officials
found 33-year-old edenlinson Velasquez
Laren an alleged gang leader of lamara
savatrucha or the MS-13 gang
good
95 Colorado boy Henry Union
Henry Union Edward 56 Toyota body camera
video shows Velasquez Laren in the front
passenger seat of the vehicle with 26
year old Gabrielle Lopez at the wheel
and 31 year old Bianca Garcia in the
back seat
hello
onions
get your ID on you
how you doing doing all right is this a
rental car yes okay did you rent it okay
do you have the rental agreement on you
uh yeah
if you got them that'd be great
thank you
here I'll give this paper back to you I
see to see this one right here
thank you
video shows the Troopers speak primarily
with Garcia who translates to the men
sitting in the front
[Music]
does he not speak any English okay well
the reason I got him stops because he's
falling too close I'm not going to issue
him a citation it's just going to be a
warning
okay all right
[Music]
tailgating
Garcia explains the group is traveling
from Colorado to New York and a vehicle
that she rented gonna have it back in
Denver
gotta have it back in Denver got you on
the 13th yes that's where you guys
heading to to New York gotcha what takes
you to New York
what took you to Colorado
um
what is it uh it's Amazon delivery oh
okay I saw a set of Amazon on here oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah so there's your
company Runner or did you rent it no I
remember it
okay because that's where I work so oh
that's okay that's why it's on here then
worldwide discount do you get a discount
for it well because if
Amazon account to Davis okay
it's like a gift card after I returned
your vehicle gotcha gotcha how long are
you staying in New York for
eign
[Applause]
you know these guys he's my fiance okay
oh okay gotcha the trooper then asks
about work visas
you hear on papers
does he have papers I'll be here
like a work visa or
yeah
no okay
thank you
body camera video then shows Velasquez
Laren hand the trooper a passport
Salvador okay gotcha all right
I'm not going to issue citation or
anything like that or I almost got to
run your information make sure there's
no once more make sure you guys okay all
right thank you when the trooper returns
he's accompanied by a border patrol
agent both Velasquez Laren and Lopez are
asked to exit the vehicle
this agent wants to speak to you he's
gonna be stepped out okay
four days in the car okay
I'll have you come out here real quick
any weapons
come back here for me okay after that
Velasquez Laren is taken into custody
stand by here a second okay
foreign
according to a 48 count Federal
indictment Velasquez Laren and 23 other
alleged gang members committed quote
numerous acts of Senseless violence in
the name of loyalty to their gang
Velasquez Lawrence specifically is
accused of ordering members of a rival
gang be murdered and selling cocaine and
marijuana Alaska's Larin appeared in
federal court in Ohio last month and is
now waiting extradition to New York
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie